[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAQUES CLAPAUCH: Hi, my
name is Jaques Clapauch
and I'm a software
engineer at Two Sigma.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS:
Hi, I'm Sam Srinivas.
I'm a product manager
and director in GCP.
And I work in security topics.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH: And we're
here to present Two Sigma
implementing fintech
security in the cloud.
So to begin with,
what is Two Sigma?
We're a technology-driven
investment manager
that uses data science
to derive insights
that forecast the future and
uncover value in the markets
worldwide.
And we do so using technologies
like AI and ML and a lot--
and I repeat, a lot-- of
distributed computing.
So for this topic, what
we want to emphasize
is the fact that we have
very, very high value IP.
That is probably one of the
more important points for us
because unlike a
lot of companies,
unlike maybe some of you
guys, if we have a breach,
it's not just a little problem.
It's a big problem because
if anyone else has our IP
or we don't have our IP, we
can't exactly go forward.
So what is our problem
in that sense, then?
So we want to strike the
right balance between security
and access.
So on one hand, we want
a secure environment
where we can protect ourselves
from external and internal
threats.
But at the same
time, we don't want
to block our developers,
our modelers,
our stakeholders in general
from accessing that data.
And who are those stakeholders?
We actually have quite
a large number of them.
We have our internal
users, which
are the people inside Two Sigma
that process a lot of data
and run models on them.
And this is internal data.
And on the converse
side of that,
we have our external
users, which also
process a large amount of data.
But in this case, it's
external data to Two Sigma.
And under them, we have these
modelers that take that data
and create models
and implement them.
And over that, we also
have this community,
which are people that use our
products that aren't directly
connected to us.
For instance, we
have this game called
Halite, which our artificial
intelligence challenge
that has thousands
and thousands of users
from across the globe
running arbitrary code.
And we have them as
stakeholders as well.
And under all of that, we
have our internal developers
that build the tools for
all of these people to use.
And of course, we also
have our security team
that also want to build secure
tools on top of the cloud,
and that want to keep
that cloud protected
using least privilege.
So what are we
going to do today?
Today we're going to talk
to you step by step how
to build your own
security on GCP
that somewhat
mimics what we have,
a simulacrum of what we have.
And we're going to
start from scratch
and build it slowly
and build it easily
in a very abstract
and easy to understand
way, such that you can
benefit from our hindsight.
In what way?
Well, as we build things from
scratch, we had our problems.
And we followed some paths
that really lead nowhere.
And we had to go back,
and we had to redo.
And that took time.
But right now, we're
going to walk you
through the exact
path in the right way,
so you can do it the
right way the first time.
And I also want to
emphasize again,
this isn't exactly how it
looks like internally to us.
But it's close
enough that it can
be abstracted to all of you.
And so to start
with, or to end with,
this is what you're going to
have when all is well and done.
Of course, don't
be scared by that.
We're going to walk you step
by step from the beginning
how to get to this
complex image right now.
And Sam is going to take over
and talk you through that.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS:
Thank you, Jaques.
So as Jaques said, you saw
the complex diagram just
before this.
We're going to
start from scratch
and build, layer by layer, as
to get there in each point.
You will have an understanding
of why we did that.
And you can follow that as a
kind of a high-level road map.
You could follow each level.
We'll talk about what
threats we were considering.
And you might follow
the same thing
when setting up an
environment from scratch.
So here is something
where there is nothing.
Two Sigma has just
come on to GCP.
Their super admins
have just signed up,
so obviously need some guard or
kind of admin to set things up.
And they've set up
an organization.
Nothing has been set up yet.
And on this side, obviously
they have their existing
on-prem data center,
and that has some kind
of local computing already.
Their servers have existed.
And very importantly,
it has the root
of all their identity, which
is Active Directory, which
is where all the employees and
perhaps contractors and so on
are.
So the very first
step, basically,
is to connect up the identities
from their Active Directory
onto the Google Cloud setup.
So what here you're
doing is to ensure
that in Google Cloud Platform,
when you're writing an IAM
rule, every
developer, every Joe,
every Alice is available
with their group settings.
And to do that, Two
Sigma use a tool which
is available GCDS, that's
Google Cloud Directory Sync.
It works with Active Directory
and synchronizes all your user
and group information
onto the Google Cloud.
And going a step further, at
this point, you could actually,
if you were doing this, you
could say, well, that's great.
Now I would like to use
Google as a primary login
to my system.
So in other words, you go
to the Google login page.
Your developer logs in.
And now they're ready to set up
a VM or whatever it might be.
But you have another choice.
And that's the choice
which Two Sigma made.
Two Sigma was using an Active
Directory as their SSO.
And they chose to stick
with Active Directory as SSO
for reasons which Jaques
will come back later.
In their use case,
it was important.
And that, again, is
possible to set up.
The Google login system can
run headless, so to speak,
and instead can federate on
to Active Directory which
is set up with a SAML.
And so the user experience
would be, for a developer,
you see the familiar
Active Directory web login.
And then you actually are
now logged into Google,
and you can be ready
to set up resources.
Now setting up resources,
let's talk about what that is.
So obviously the only reason
you have your on-the-cloud
is to have computing
and data and so on.
So here basically there are
three canonical examples
we have in this
abstract diagram.
And these actually
very much apply
to, obviously, what
Two Sigma really did.
They have a bunch of Linux VMs.
And the Linux VMs
actually embody
that custom IP which
Jacques was talking about.
They might be doing some custom
modeling, a very high-value IP.
And they're running
models and so forth.
There's an App
Engine application,
and the App Engine application
is the control for this.
In other words,
if I'm a developer
and an external modeler, one of
the user types he talked about,
you would see a web interface.
You would do various
things in it.
And at the back, you'd
be running the models
on these Linux VMs,
and, of course,
data stored in Cloud Storage.
So the first step--
again, we're doing
this systematically,
so you'd say create these
resources at this point.
And we haven't yet set them
up to be locked down securely.
What first step do we take?
And what did Two Sigma
do to lock them down?
The very first step is
obviously to use IAM.
So all security really--
and I think it's a
fair thing to say--
is about controlling
who can access what.
And the first step is to say
that App Engine setup can only
be manipulated by
our DevOps group.
And similarly, something
similar for the Linux VMs.
Maybe it's some other
group or maybe it's DevOps.
And similarly for the cloud
storage access policy.
So when you set these up, what
that means is that obviously
locking down in a very
big way, you can't--
for example, I could be logged
in as some Gmail account.
And I can't access this anymore.
And however, at this point,
I'll just make a point
that somebody in
the DevOps group
can maintain that App Engine
or change the settings, IAM
settings or whatever it
might be, or use APIs
against against App Engine.
They could do it
from their office,
but they could do
it from anywhere.
And just hold that
thought in your mind.
So at this point, we have
locked down these resources
with basic IAM.
So I'll give it back
to Jaques to tell us
what we've done so far.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH:
So what did we do?
We set up GCP using our
super admin account.
We synced our user
identities using AD
and now we have that
direct connectivity there.
And we set up our
first resources.
We now have VMs.
We have buckets.
And we have the raw access
control rules for them.
But not everything
is perfect right now.
Now we have some concerns.
We set everything up
using the super admin.
And he has very,
very large powers.
So how can we make sure that
that can't be compromised,
that a third party can't
gain access to that
and do evil things, or if,
you know, the super admin
can't do something by mistake?
We do have all those resources.
And they are accessible
by Two Sigma.
But they're also accessible
outside Two Sigma.
And that isn't necessarily
something we want.
We want something
that our developers
can use but not elsewhere.
And again, all resources now
can be accessed everywhere.
We don't really have
any block, any firewall,
anything prohibiting them
from using it elsewhere.
And finally, our developers
want to use Kerberos.
They want to sign into
things directly using it.
And we currently don't
really have a way
to sync that through our AD.
So Sam will tell us how
to resolve those issues.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS: So
the first point Jaques
made was the super
admin privilege
is pretty scary because this
is like a God privilege.
And you always
need that in the--
you're setting up your cloud.
You're always going to have
some foundational account which
has set up.
You want to reduce it
to as few as possible,
but you're still going
to have something.
And that's not going to
be necessarily on your SSO
because this is essentially
a bootstrap sccount.
So how can we make
that more secure?
So the big concern you have with
account security is phishing.
Of course, you might
put a password.
Obviously, there's a password.
You might put an OTP on this.
That's very good progress.
But for something which
could potentially shut down
in production systems
or whatever, that's
the kind of privileges
this admin has,
we'd want to lock down further.
And what Two Sigma
has done is it's
used an MFA protocol,
the security key,
and shut down and locked down
the sessions to be very short.
And let me tell you a little
bit more about security key.
So as I said, phishing is
the number one log in attack.
However, sophisticated
user might be--
there typically is
a very crafted way
where when they're
not paying attention,
you can actually
try and phish them
for their login credentials.
And any, what's called
a better credential--
think anything which you
can type somewhere-- you can
be typing in the wrong place.
So that obviously applies to
passwords, applies to OTPs.
Now we're not trying to
sell OTPs down the river.
OTPs are a huge step up.
But for the what's at stake
here, we have to go further.
And what the security
key gives you
is essentially a second
factor specifically designed
to defeat phishing.
Now defeat is a strong word.
Nothing is perfect, but it
inherently has this design.
And so how does that work?
Let's talk about user
experience first.
Real security key,
you're the super admin,
you type in, login password.
You stick a key into USB
port and press a button.
What's happening behind the
covers on the server side
when it verifies the second
factor are two things.
Firstly, each of these
keys-- a crypto key,
it has a private keypad
only to the account,
so of course, it verifies
that, hey, here's
a signature from this particular
account, which is a key which
is attached to this account.
Secondly, the
signature area, what
is within the signed
boundary, also
has what the URL
that the browser
is seeing in actually
where you type over there,
basically the eTLD.
That's a pretty key thing.
Effectively, the server can see
where did your type in the log
in and password?
Did you type it at Google.com
or fake Google.com.
And in fact, that is what
prevents the phishing angle.
And so it's a very significant
upgrade to security.
And so the foundational
super admin log ins
are locked down this way.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH: And you also
get one really nice bonus
from this.
And it's an unwarranted
bonus from the key.
But basically now, you
can have multi-party off.
The idea is, if you can share
your password with one party,
and you can share the
key with another party,
suddenly you can make sure
that anytime someone logs
into that account,
it needs to have
both of those people in, kind of
like in those old movies where
two people had to turn the key
to launch the launches, yeah.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS: Yeah.
In fact, that's a
very interesting use
which Two Sigma made,
which typically, you
might say that's great and
all, this add super admin,
make it even more secure.
I don't want just a Joe or
Alice to have power to do this.
They might go rogue on me,
or they might make a mistake.
They've effectively
used this feature
to separate out the privileges.
So Joe's got the password,
and Alice has got the key.
And as a minor point, you can
actually have multiple keys
to an account.
So you can have Alice and
Jane and Bob, perhaps,
if you so choose, any two
of them kind of thing.
So going back to what
Jaques had said, he said,
well, there are various things
wrong, which I want to improve.
One thing was locking
down the admin account.
The next thing which he
pointed out was initially
we set up, for
example, the App Engine
to be accessed only by DevOps.
But you can also
have that App Engine
instance to be
accessed or controlled
by any identity in Google.
That's a feature, not a bug.
For example, in
your case, you might
say we want this contractor
or that company which
we have a deal with to be
able to control our resources.
However, in their case, they
want to have a lockdown.
They want to ensure that
these resources cannot be even
accidentally allowed access to
anybody other than an identity
from Two Sigma.
And so here again,
they enable something
which is what was called
an org wide policy.
So you got your
organization, the container
in which all the
resources live, and you
can put an org wide policy,
which essentially says
in plain English, allow
only Two Sigma entities
to be having control on these.
And so what that really does
is basically prevent any kind
of inadvertent mistakes.
So for example, someone in
a project, a junior engineer
project, somebody he or she
might have a bright idea
to just share some data directly
with an external contractor
with all good intention.
But this essentially
prevents that.
So there are other org
wide policies, too,
which Two Sigma chose to use.
And again this might work or
would be useful for you also.
And in their case, for example,
they set up a policy where a VM
image, which is
used in one project,
cannot be shared
with another project.
And Jaques, maybe you
can tell us a little bit
about the motivation here.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH:
So this is an issue
for which we were pioneers.
We found out
firsthand that Google
had added a specific feature
that allowed you to move images
from within projects,
which is actually
quite a useful feature,
because in a lot of cases,
you do want to do that.
For us, however, that's
an exfiltration vector.
That means that we can have
a very locked down project
and a non-locked down
project within the same org.
And suddenly we can
copy that image that
has all our private IP
to the other project
and then take everything out.
And we came to Google
with that problem.
And we said, you know, we
don't necessarily want that.
And Google came around and
made us this specific org
to help us to specifically
block that, which
is a great boon to Googles.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS: Yeah.
So like Jaques
said, in their case,
they have multiple kinds
of stakeholders and users.
And then there were different
policies relevant to each.
And this prevents the
information sharing
at the very image level.
So going on to one more
again, it is the team here
being org wide control.
You set them up at
organization level.
One of the control that
they chose to set up
is that they allowed no
serial port access to VMs.
Serial port access to
VMs, again, is a feature.
It might be in your case,
you might want to allow that.
But in their case, they did not.
And just to recap,
you bring up a VM.
If it's on the network,
you can SSH to it.
But then, there might be
some network config issue.
It might not be accessible.
The serial port is
the sub network.
You're accessing it
in course directly.
And that's what we allow.
But in their case, they
chose not to allow that.
And Jaques, maybe you can
tell us what drove that.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH: Sure, so again,
that access is unrestricted.
It is useful.
If you have a network, if you
have a machine that's breaking,
and you can't get
through the network,
and you configured
something wrong somewhere,
and you really have
to get to that VM,
this is the way to do it.
And it's useful.
But again, for us, that's
an exfiltration vector.
It means somebody can forego
all of the network rules
and just go directly into
your project, into your VM,
and take everything
out, as long as they
know the password, which I'm
sure malicious people can get.
So we wanted to block that.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS: So
let's take a little bit
of a stock of where we are.
So we have set up an
integrated set of policies.
Every one of those
yellow lines that you
see, it represents basically
a policy which we-- you
saw us setting up.
So at the App Engine instance,
the Compute Engine instances,
the Cloud Storage, we set up
policies, the group level,
as you remember.
The super admins
are locked down so
that they can only have a
phishing resistant log in,
have short sessions.
The admin uses
identity effectively.
They are delegated down
from active vectoring.
That's the policy.
And the box around a Two Sigma
organization-- if you remember,
we set policies saying
that you can't share
ID resources from outside.
Your can't copy images.
You can't lock down
serial port and so forth.
So let's take some stock here.
And I'll give that
back to Jaques now.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH: So we now lock
down our super admin log in.
Super admins now don't
have god-like powers.
We now didn't allow resources to
be shared outside of Two Sigma
identities.
So people outside
Two Sigma really
can't access anything yet.
But we still haven't
solved everything.
Resources can still be
accessed from anywhere.
And we still don't have our much
desired Kerberos for our deps.
And Sam's going to walk us
through how we get that.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS: So network
layer control, as all of us
know, we want multiple
layers of access controls.
And one conservative and obvious
access control mechanism is
to put a network boundary around
a set of resources and make
sure they cannot be accessed
from anywhere but there.
So that's called a VPC.
And in this slide, we
show the first step
of a VPC, which is
around the Linux VMs.
And there it's the
classic network construct.
You have a bunch
of Linux machines,
and you put, basically,
a firewall around them.
And they cannot open a VPC
connection or SSH or whatever,
SAP out from the boundary.
And similarly, they
are private IPs.
They can't be accessed
from the outside.
That's interesting.
But we want to bring
that notion of VPC
not just to just a translation
of the physical pass,
but also to these virtual
constructs or these Cloud
constructs, which is the App
Engine and the Cloud storage.
And how do we do that?
So what is a mechanism
for doing so?
And so essentially, we want
to say these things cannot be
accessed from the outside.
So there again, as you can
imagine, it's in the Cloud.
Everything is policy
and config driven.
And on the VPC, you
set a resource policy
to do precisely that.
So in effect, here the
plain English notion
is you can't access data from
the outside on a containing
VPC, from outside
the containing VPC.
And what that really means is
that that App Engine instance,
the Cloud storage instance, now
that management or the access
to the APIs, if you remember
before, they were locked down
to the dev ops
group or whatever,
the dev ops group can no
longer do it from anywhere
on the internet.
They can only do it
if their source IP
are within the private network.
So in effect, bringing
these abstractions
which Google is
providing you also
within the notion of
a network boundary.
So having said that,
the next step we do
is this VPC obviously is
like what you would expect.
It is a private network and you
connect it up to your on prem.
And what Two Sigma chose to do
is there are multiple options.
You can use either a site to
site VPN or something called
a private interconnect.
And they chose to use
a private interconnect
and that gives them
some amazing speeds,
a 60 gigabit connection.
So in this context, we're
talking about security,
but it's also
really, really fast.
So the connection, once
you connected up to your
on premise, your VPC,
which is on the Cloud,
that brings us to the solution
for the fourth problem which
Jaques talked about.
Which is basically that the
developers we used before when
on prem, if you see the
local compute on the on prem,
they were used to getting a
Kerberos ticket from Active
Directory and logging into
their Linux machines on prem.
They want the exact
same thing, basically,
on the virtual machines
which are now on Cloud.
And this, when you hook
up the network this way,
you have the
private connectivity
and the Kerberos ticket now
can travel over the network.
And so you can get
Kerberos access to the VMs.
And so that basically gets us
to where the list of questions
we had.
And I'll give this
back to Jaques here.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH: So as
we talked about before,
we had already
solved one and two.
So on to three and four.
We now have the VPC.
So now data can't be easily
exfiltrated from that.
And we enabled Kerberos,
so now our developers
can just sign in
to things directly
without all that hassle.
But we're still
not 100% there yet.
So a bad insider can't copy
the data out of the network.
We locked it down, right?
But we only did it directly.
What if someone
indirectly takes the data,
copies it to another
GCP resource,
and takes it out from
that open GCP resource,
like a personal bucket?
So buckets have encryption
by default, which is good.
But we have compliance issues.
And we need to manage the keys
so we can give good compliance
visibility.
And right now, no
resources can be
accessed from outside the
VPC, but sometimes you
want to give access.
We want people from the
internet to have access
to some of our data.
So how can we do that
securely in a way that doesn't
break what we have right now?
And Sam's going to
talk about that.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS:
Thanks, Jaques.
So the first problem that
Jaques talked about was,
do we set up a VPC boundary?
And though it was the case that
that App Engine instance now
cannot be accessed by Joe in
dev ops unless Joe in dev ops is
within the VPC network, so to
speak, there's still a problem.
Which is that, if Joe
goes rogue, in principle,
or even Joe, by making
an inadvertent mistake,
could set up instance
of a personal bucket
and could make a copy from
the data which is inside
a VPC to the personal bucket.
In essence, we don't
have an outbound--
at that point, at this
point of the build,
we don't have an outbound
firewall, so to speak,
which prevents
you from accessing
any resource within GCP,
a GCP resource which
is not within your VPC.
So this precisely now
what we add as a policy.
So we add a policy saying, no
GCP resources outside my VPC
can be accessed
from inside the VPC.
So you can think of, for
example all Cloud buckets
and GCP now broken
into two sets.
One is the sets which
are within your VPC,
as you have designated,
and one is everything else.
It doesn't matter who owns them.
It could be your organization
or somebody else.
Now those, even though the
API endpoint for, obviously,
Cloud services are accessible,
you cannot access those
particular resources.
And so this cuts out this
huge exfiltration vector.
And you can think of this as a
completion step, where you're
truly bringing just your Cloud
resources within your network
boundary.
And this is feature, in
case you're looking for it,
is called VPC service
control and is
something that you might want
to enable in your setup also.
The next point which
Jaques talked about
was that, if you use our
storage offerings, by default,
all data's encrypted at best.
And we manage the keys, or
Google manages the keys.
But for visibility or for
compliance, in your case,
you might say, I want
that key management.
And luckily, Google
provides a feature for that,
with the Cloud key management--
KMS feature.
And so what happens is that
you set up an instance of Cloud
KMS, and in this case, was Two
Sigma to manage their KMS keys.
And again, it's policy driven.
You're effectively--
in essence, you
are setting the Cloud
storage instances
to use keys that
you're managing.
And that's a policy.
So once again, it's software
driven, config driven.
And so at this point, we
have solved the problem
of the visibility of our
control over the keys,
which are key management,
which Jaques was looking for.
And that brings us to the
next point that Jaques made.
So the only reason you build
systems are for access.
And in the end, some
subset of users,
you want them to have community
access, ideally from anywhere
and safely.
And so here the end
users in their set
up could be employees, could
be those external modelers.
And Jacques told us there
were six classes of users.
How do we enable--
you don't want
to bring them all inside
your production network,
obviously, for access.
You want to keep them
outside, but give them
safe access to what
you want to publish.
And that's precisely
what the IAP allows.
So IAP stands for
identity of a proxy.
So it is essentially
a reverse proxy front
end, which is internet facing
for your back end application.
If you remember, we talked
about this back end App Engine
application.
And as I said, that's
a web application
written by Two Sigma to
essentially provide a unified
front end to all the
complex processing happening
at the back model
running and so on.
How do you take that
application and publish it
to the internet
in a safe fashion?
That's precisely what IAP does.
So in this case, you'll
see this name TwoSigma.com.
They're publishing an
application, TwoSigma.com
securely to the internet.
When you come to TwoSigma.com
as a user from the internet,
the backend application
are hitting.
Really, this is back end
App Engine application.
However, there's a
bit more to that.
You can essentially write--
what Two Sigma has done is
use the IAM features of IAP.
You can write in policies as to
who can access the application.
So in this case-- we just
made up this example.
Maybe this TwoSigma.com
application
can be accessed only by
the contractors group.
Just say so.
And what happens is that,
at every HTTPS request,
the actual user logged
in as validated by IAP.
And if the policy allows, it
sends the hit to the back end.
If not, it sends you a
polite page, saying sorry,
you're not allowed
access to this resource.
The nice thing about this is
that the back end App Engine
application was written with
no particular access controls
baked into it.
Because you never know.
Tomorrow you might want some
other group to access it.
So now your
infrastructure, which
IAP enables you to essentially
add these access controls
right in the front
end, and provide you
just the limited
access that you want.
So let me give it back to
Jaques to see where we are now
in this journey.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH:
So right now, we
make sure that insiders
can't misuse the resources
to indirectly take data out.
We mange the encryption
keys to make sure
all the storage is
compliant and visible--
the keys are invisible.
And we published the end
user applications safely
to the internet so people can
now use our services outside.
But of course, we do
have one last issue.
And as my colleague,
Nick Orfanidis always
quotes, if you feel
that you're 100% secure
and you haven't
been broken into,
you likely have
been broken, into
and you just don't
know about it.
So no security is 100% perfect.
And for the cases where
it actually does go wrong,
because things do
go wrong, we need
to be able to figure out
what went wrong, check on it,
and fix it later.
So for that, we need status
and we need forensics.
And for that, we have
a number of tools.
Initially, we have
Stackdriver, which
gives us the logs that tells
us who did what when, not why,
but what and when.
We have CSCC, which gives
us a console that tells us
the consolidated
status of everything
that we have in
our organization.
And finally, we have Google's
Forseti, with the open source
tool Forseti, to
automate the monitoring
and the setting up of policies.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS:
And I guess one thing
I should mention for
those who don't know,
is CSCC stands for Cloud
Security Command Center.
It's essentially intended
to be a central console,
very good visibility into
all your security monitoring.
And Forseti is a set
of open source tools
that we have offered-- look
at Forseti.org-- specifically
so you can automate setting
up and monitoring of policies
in GCP and beyond, actually.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH: And
finally, we come back
to our finalized picture
of what we should
have if you want a secure
environment with all
the features that Google has.
So we finally got to
that level that we want.
We want secure inside,
outside, and we have not built
any walls for our developers.
As the quote I
often say, it says,
build guardrails, not walls.
So everything is usable,
everything is secure,
and we did it simply step by
step so you guys can follow it.
And to sum it up,
Two Sigma-- we're
a fintech company with extremely
high value IP, like many of you
might have.
And as I said, we need
to lock everything down,
but make access easy.
And we need a hybrid
solution that spans
both Cloud and on prem.
And by using GCP,
we get a control
to do so securely, easily, and
still use a lot of features.
And because of them, we're
able to easily stitch
all of that together
to exact our needs.
So Sam will tell us how--
where we can go next.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS: So
the core principle
in what we were doing, which
really applies to Cloud really,
is that, as I said,
controlling access is what
really security is all about.
And so at every point, we
were using access controls,
identity driven access controls,
to say who can access what.
So here when we say who,
it was people things.
So this group of people
can access this application
published out to the internet.
This group of people can set
this App Engine instance,
but only if they're in
this context, for example,
from within the
VPC and so forth.
The next step
essentially is to--
but however, at this
stage of the conversation,
when Linux VM called
another Linux VM,
basically it was
a TCP connection.
Maybe it called some API.
But that was not a named
thing at this point.
And so where Two Sigma is--
we are having conversations is
to take the notion of identity
driven access, not
just for human beings,
but as the services themselves.
Which I'm sure you've been
listening to the keynotes
when we talk about Istio and
Apogee, that's what it's about.
So now every service
actually has a name.
And you can set policies, which
the platform allows you to do,
where before you could say
only Joe can access API.
Now you can say which services
can access what other service.
And so everything that
gets published is APIs,
and you actually have
interservice controls
on a service and
data driven basis.
And so that's the next stage.
So you can just think of kicking
the notion of security controls
further and further
up the stack.
Not that the lower layers
become obviated by any means.
The network layers are
extremely important.
But basically, once
you put them there,
they are sort of-- so maybe
I use the word "fairly"--
crude at beginning because they
don't have the higher level
concepts.
And then you basically now
focus your security setup
more of the identity
layers for both individuals
and for services.
And that's where
that conversation
is going with Two Sigma,
and Istio and Apogee.
And they have been a
partner for us, actually,
in driving many of the
controls that we put in.
And we look forward
to their feedback.
And the same thing and
similarly from all of you--
please join us in this journey.
Use what you've
got, and then set up
all the controls that you have
and tell us what's missing.
And so help us
drive it where it's
complete from your perspective.
There may be other controls
which are not relevant to them
which you might need
which we are not aware of.
Let's talk about that.
JAQUES CLAPAUCH: And I
can't emphasize that enough.
Always, always work with Google.
Because no matter where you
go, what you do anywhere,
nothing will be
100% what you need.
But working with
Google, you can get
to that 100% of what you need.
And they will help, and they're
actually very, very helpful--
from AMs to PMs to temps
to everyone at Google,
they really, really
help you drive to where
your solution needs to go.
SAMPATH SRINIVAS:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]